the [ __ ] is mine
leave your entries in the subreddits
and i'll watch submissions in the next
episode of floyd
the war is already won i found a
loophole in the pewdiepie versus t
series what nunny youtube's music
is at 105 million subscribers who the
hell is pewdiepie's wage slave
so t-series would not be the first
channel to get 200 million
but pewdiepie would be the first
youtuber to get
to 1 million
holy heck guys this changes everything
oh my god we win by default well we
still have to hit
a hundred million brof is at 100 million
if pewds starts a family we would have
three pikes
cutie pie pewdiepie and the kid would be
named
cream pie
now hold leave your visit a historical
place today
you found just a spot didn't you people
are visiting from all across the world
to speak
to be at this holy spot what video did
you make
this week that you're proud of share
below the one you demonetized
cool you basically still put my name all
over a panda's tweet
everyone's like it's against it's big
corporations versus
individuals meanwhile me big creator
stomping all over the smaller youtubers
i cracked the system did you know if
felix puts a giant watermark on the
screen
whenever he says something controversial
stating this was taken out of context
the media cannot use it as evidence now
they'll just use it as a quote anyway
well listen i'm not trying to get them
that hunting media rhetoric but
they can just take whatever as a quote
and say that's it
it's not like they're going to be oh
there was a watermark on this
saying it was out of context turns down
quality to
240p to save mobile data
youtube loads two minutes and in 1080p
60fps my data plan this is so
sad i am crying in a nutshell if you
don't get this y'all going to hell
stop dating boys who don't understand
this okay
bob
[Music]
what is that
the gun whichever
will it be
sit the frick down this game is still
relevant number one in trending gaming
holy heck guys that's it from now on
i'm a happy wheels gamer 100 episodes
let's go gamers modern problems require
older solutions
more happy wheels coming soon and then
minecraft and then more happy wheels
we're gonna we're gonna go full loop on
this channel we're gonna go back to the
call of duty commentaries when you clap
your hands two times but no one in your
friend group
screams meme review idiots
stepped on holy ground there it is
another another pilgrimage
from another nine year old thank you
very cool avengers deleted scene
avengers thanos ass looks like he has
ass implants and the
silicone was turned upside down if
you've seen those videos
i'm disappointed i thought thanos was
thick
when you were supposed to have memes
running on you but nobody cares anymore
sad static
stop crying this guy will reach 100 mil
one day and 1.3
of the population will be subbed to him
jesus
christ what is wrong with our planet
is there nothing more important
happening right now
is that when we hit 8 million someone
common today this man was from the
future
he predicted the future you know when we
hit 16 that's when things started going
feeling ridiculous to me that's when i
went like
okay this at this point i'm just seeing
how far we can push
it 100 ml jesus king christ
can we get the same likes as dislikes
can this video get same likes and stick
like
it's still going
still perfectly balanced as all things
should be
only it's almost hit a million damn if
this can hit
1 mil 10 million views at the same time
they hit a million comments
that would be lit as freak here you go
proves ricardo is the best
girlfriend average build ricardo rip
this
girlfriend needs constant attention
ricardo
only has attention to give girlfriend
clean shaven face ricardo god like a
goatee that's right
if your girlfriend doesn't have a goatee
it's time to yeely that girl
go away girlfriend usually wears a shirt
excuse me girl never wore a shirt in his
laugh
that's okay kids ricardo
monster picks takes an hour to prepare
hair
bandana wheeled it into his skull
girlfriend new superman abilities
ricardo
immortal benz the universe at his will
ricardo the only man who can defeat
thanos if he doesn't appear in end game
marvel whatever
that movie is called then i'm gonna have
to make why i don't like marvel vue
movies part two
that's right the most controversial
video i have ever uploaded on this
channel
pewdiepie is the only rapper in history
to write a diss track
so fire he got banned from a continent
thus making him the greatest rapper of
all time
2019 um it never fails to amaze me hate
time magazine i fixed your list if a
person who has gotten billionaires to
talk memes
raised hundreds of thousands for charity
and started a worldwide movement to
subscribe doesn't make your list
it's not a very good list damn matpat
with the support thank you very much
that's really sweet of you i understand
tyne
they they can't acknowledge people that
they feel like is
doing something negative at least
that's how i interpreted it well donald
trump is on it so
felix get pewdiepie's dad to tell us
embarrassing childhood stories
felix he has none because i was perfect
child
in every single way possible who's mom
we used to call you felicia
because you like dressing up as a girl
when you were a kid
i have no memory of this just for the
record maybe i have a faint memory
because you know why i'll tell you why
okay
there's nothing wrong with breaking down
gender stereotypes i wanted to dress up
as her okay
she was my favorite character don't
judge me
so i remember going to school with the
one of the that haircut
i must have been like three years old
like
post with 10k upvotes that has nothing
to do with pewdiepie
my down vote i kind of like that the
subreddit is just not about me
i don't mind that at all have someone
make an addiction where they're obsessed
with pewdiepie
go on dr phil dr phil shows pewdiepie's
content
pewdiepie copy strikes dr phil sony
wait a minute that's illegal what if i
go on dr phil talking about my g fuel
addiction
[Music]
10 off code pewdiepie can i copy strike
myself
this rain bow
is stick
red
what is it minus or is it connected this
rainbow
this rain
this gay hmm
this game is
why am i so slow come on i can do this
stink
[Music]
is it mine i don't get it
is it sick
relevant god damn
it
this game is still relevant god
oh
[Music]
hey guys i'm 13 year old nine year old
over
what the what did i just read i'm a 13
year old nine
[Music]
i've saved up four hundred dollars for
this chair and now i finally have it i'm
not rich or even close to it
but this is my own money that i worked
hard for thanks
do you need help assembling it i'll come
over
it looks like you're having some trouble
there if you want a good chair
i want to support me at the same time i
do very very
very very much appreciate it i hope one
day i can give back in a better way that
than what i've been doing stop dating
boys who don't understand this jesus
christ another one
guys i can't do this exit your
i don't like when it says end that makes
me scared what does the end mean
exit your
[Music]
tree your
your new tree in
the sub reddit
bro fist and
what the hell is god damn it's like
it's too hard i can't do it
things hit your what is it it's a tree
exit your your
an entry
exit your entry entry that's what it is
in leave your entries in the song ready
bro
and i'll
watch summation
no
5 000 iq i am the smartest man
i am the smartest there has ever been
smart
don't question my power for i will
destroy
all of you pewdiepie
can we go this like a pie that looks
delicious
leave your in whoa
that looks sick paper bag head
10 out of 10 dude or
last damn that's so cool
whoa heck yeah
sharingan style baby i am so sorry
well it's time to end that episode there
thank you guys so much for all the
lovely
supports and epicness and creativity
smash like subscribe brophy said 100
million
profits to god and i'll see you guys
next time
bye tuber simulator it's now so relevant
that it's got a brand new minigame
craniac
drop the crane and get fresh items only
available
in the washing machine like game and you
say there's more
of course there is new knowledge perks
new quests and new pixellings and
legs guys like